[Music]
we hang out a lot and your this
gentleman's favorite thing in the world
is Bud Light you love your Bud Light
do you think you'd be a good
spokesperson for Bud Light I could do
that I could do it because if you
believe in something then people can see
this all right I keep one of these
behind my desk yeah and I'd why don't
you just show us what what's the Bud
Light ad that you would do pick a camera
there and go right to it yeah sure
ah Bud Light it's good and good for you
please drink responsibly you just add
please drink responsibly
yes responsible human being yeah and
it's cold y'all this goes with
everything it's so good does it go with
pro killing yeah
you